welcome to this video when time playing
haga of course one be three radium is
this guy is playing one be three in
every single game isn't this a bit
one-sided just a little bit okay so I
played them this captions six allowing
me this type of position looks quite
nice actually okay so should I take yeah
come on let's take this should give me a
good piece play Bishop f5 or maybe SF
yes sir you for even okay let's just
just develop
okay so what's the plan may be here with
night before possible and maybe maybe I
can just try for for a very crude attack
but it served it's not so easy this yeah
well I thought I can I can maybe just
take I mean on age three quite often
this is possible yeah come on let's do
it and the shackling d7 King edge 1 and
27 mr. something else 27,000 ig1 of
course yeah so they can go look g one
Queen age three yeah well come on check
and now I'm threatening on edge too yeah
this is Sir at least well wow I can I
thought I have a draw but I can take
only 3 with the night attacking of the
Queen also and made on g2 that should
actually win the game white resigns wow
I wasn't really aware of that but then
maybe this is good I mean okay it's
probably good until I check it with the
comp let's see no black is winning
hahaha I really got that one right black
wins he does he cannot afford to take
this is funny check I mean this is all
along known known lines in another type
of and other positions but the chest
working like perfection right cool very
cool and he doesn't even have this one
because I can i can get everything with
check and at the end i'll meet him just
like that Jack very nice so you must he
must play that basically and after that
just 93 and it's gone I just win the
Queen that's cool and this is the
additional made thread yeah the sauce
this was very very tight game actually
so what will h3 is a bit I don't know
and this is really playing with fire but
it's working to perfection amazingly
enough alright thanks for watching